let's not embellish the reality. This winter
will be difficult, so once again I urge everyone to
carefully prepare for winter. It is desirable that
every family should have a stock of necessary
basic things, warm clothes, candles,
flashlights, batteries. It is important to
prepare in case the light or heat disappears as a result of
massive rocket attacks,
we are on our side  together
with the local authorities, they accumulated a sufficient
amount of energy resources, prepared the
networks, purchased additional equipment, for three
days in a row, the enemy is launching missile strikes and
also using kamikaze drones against
our civil and energy
infrastructure, this day alone there have been
8 shellings in three regions of
Ukraine, 128 shellings have been recorded in the last three days
alone  as a result,
more than 200 different objects were damaged
, including 28 objects of the energy
infrastructure, the blows were inflicted both on the
generation and on the distribution of
electricity at the same time.
in order to avoid
overloading, the power industry switches off the
lights according to the schedule, now readiness for the
heating season in the country is more
than 90%.  special
heating points for the population have also been prepared,
evacuation plans have been developed in the event of the impossibility of
quickly restoring critical
infrastructure Today, I once again want
to appeal to all Ukrainians with a
request to reduce
electricity consumption in the evening hours, it is not
about sitting in the dark, it is
only necessary to reduce the use of the most
energy-intensive devices  we appeal
to businesses to join conscious
consumption and in the specified period from
17:00 to 22:00 to turn off outdoor
light advertising and other energy-consuming
devices, such a responsible approach
allows us to minimally apply
shutdown schedules